closing arguments happened yesterday
this is preceded by the judge in the
case dropping the the
charge the gun charge against kyle
rittenhouse according to abc news
rittenhouse was 17 when he shot three
people killing two with a semi-automatic
rifle on the streets of kenosha
wisconsin during a protest against
police brutality last year i love how
they they characterized that not a bunch
of people running around rioting it was
just a protest against police brutality
prosecutors brought multiple charges
against him including first-degree
intentional homicide attempted homicide
reckless endangerment and the firearm
possession count
with legal experts saying prosecutors
struggled to counter the illinois man's
claims of self-defense the best bet for
a conviction looked like the gun charge
but written house defense team dug up an
exception to the prohibition judge bruce
schrader dismissed the count monday just
hours before the jurors got the case
under wisconsin law anyone under 18 who
possesses a dangerous weapon is guilty
of a misdemeanor punishable by up to
nine months behind bars
on its face convicting written house on
that count looked like a legal slam dunk
because he was 17 years old and
obviously had the rifle strapped to his
chest before the shooting but written
house attorneys seized on a subsection
of wisconsin law that states the ban on
minors possessing dangerous weapons
applies to minors armed with rifles or
shotguns only if those weapons are
short-barreled
that language stems from a bill then
republican governor tommy thompson
signed in 1991.
lawmakers were trying to find ways to
curb a gang violence around that time
the goal was to prevent youths from
carrying sawed-off shotguns
the ar-15 was not short-barreled
they asked raider to dismiss the
possession counts on those grounds at a
pre-trial hearing in october
the judge refused to toss the charge at
that point
and then um he
did toss the charge
because
again the law is pretty specific
i mean the law says that you're not
allowed to carry a short-barreled
shotgun or short-barrelled rifle
but
it does not include these i mean if you
draw the law that way that is what the
law is
so that that charge was ruled out by the
judge immediately so basically you are
now down to the reckless endangerment
charge reckless endangerment would be
essentially shooting a gun in a crowded
place knowing that it might hit somebody
but that is going to be obviated by
self-defense in this particular case
legally speaking so the prosecution has
nothing
and they they really demonstrated that
they had nothing yesterday it was it was
a bad closing argument for the
prosecution
so the prosecutor the chief prosecutor
here's a guy him thomas binger bringer
made a mockery of himself throughout
this trial
i mean so much so that earlier in the
trial
the the judge reamed
binger for for being bad at his job
bingo literally atta i mean he almost
attempted to get a mistrial declared
through his own activity
and he realized things were going so
badly that it's almost hard to read this
as anything except for him attempting to
get a mistrial he suggested in open
court that written house not talking to
the cops was an admission of guilt
which has not been the case
pretty much ever in common law and
certainly has not been the case in
american case law for something like 40
or 50 years here is the judge dreaming
binger earlier in the trial
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that i said i
had heard nothing in this trial to
change any of my rulings so why
testimony you're on it pardon me that
was before that get brazen with me
you're an experienced trial attorney and
you're telling me that when the judge
says i'm excluding this you just to take
it upon yourself to put it in because
you think that you've found a way around
it come on
okay so
it was it was a rough road for the
prosecutors here and they just
demonstrate again i don't know where
they got their law degrees uh bingo i
think went to university of michigan law
school which really does not speak
highly of the university of michigan for
sure okay so yesterday he
just made a mockery of himself it was
truly a terrible closing argument he
began by saying something just patently
false okay which is if you bring a gun
to a situation and then somebody attacks
you and you shoot them this means that
you do not have the defense of
self-defense available to you
that's not true in any way shape or form
if i bring a gun to an area where i'm
legally allowed to bring a gun even i
bring a gun to an area where i'm not
legally allowed to bring a gun you might
get me on a gun charge but if somebody
attacks me with a knife and i shoot them
that is still self-defense if somebody
attacks me without a knife and i shoot
them that is still self-defense
depending on if i am in legitimate and
reasonable fear for my life here is
bingo just completely botching the law
again did he send like fracker jack box
tops into the into the bar association
to get a law degree i don't understand
how this guy is even practicing
and one of the things to keep in mind is
that when the defendant provokes the
incident he loses the right to
self-defense you cannot claim
self-defense against a danger you create
that's critical right here the defendant
decided to pull the trigger on his ar-15
four times
that was his decision
and he is responsible for every bullet
that comes out of that gun
so it is true that if you provoke a
confrontation you cannot then use
self-defense that part is true but he
literally said there's a direct quote
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun
nope
false
actively false so the prosecution's case
relies on the idea that written house
started a fight essentially with joseph
rosenbaum and that everything that there
upon followed was written house's fault
but there's no evidence that that's the
case
okay and and so instead you see the
prosecutor making just i mean bingo was
just is bizarre here he was defending
joseph rosenbaum joseph rosenbaum spent
the evening
being totally insane spent the evening
burning things threatening people with
chains literally saying according to
witness testimony that he would kill
rittenhouse if he found him alone
and bingor just decides that the only
way to prosecute rittenhouse is to
pretend that joseph rosenbaum was
actually like a wonderful dude so here
he is clip 14 explaining that joseph
rose's mom really didn't do anything
that he just you know it's just a
non-threatening kind of
silly idiot little guy who who really
you know there was nothing to fear from
joseph rosenbaum while he was like
threatening people chains and burning
cars and such
he just happens to stumble into it
so what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire
oh and he said some bad words he said
the n-word
the hell is wrong with this guy like
really i don't know what's wrong with
him and by the way all of the offenses
that he mentions before the n-word
offense which by the way according to
the media is the gravest defense in
american public life if you use the
n-word we borrow you from public society
we basically brand you and say that you
are no longer allowed to participate in
public society in america
he's like well he said the n-word and
that
but also like all the other stuff that
you're saying is criminal okay sexual
criminal activity it's like so he was
rioting so he was burning things so he
was setting a barricade to rent the cops
from getting in so he's i mean was that
that big a deal like he seems like a
nice guy who was he just said he's like
a bad night how many times have you just
been walking down the street and you
said a metal dumpster on fire tipped
over a porta potty started waving around
chains shouting the n-word and tried to
block the cops from coming happens all
the time happens all the time
that's the prosecutor you remember
prosecutors are supposed to be angry at
people for violating the law that's kind
of their job it's like well his
violations of law are no big deal and
then he goes even further he suggests
that this is a mob of heroes
now you watched the tape did that look
like a mob of heroes to you the people
chasing kyle rittenhouse did that look
like a group of people out for justice
that evening or did that look like a
bunch of people who are out to make
trouble and burn things and create
violence and havoc
and did it look like they were chasing
down kyle written house to beat the
living hell out of him like before the
shooting remember he's being chased
by rosenbaum and other people before he
shoots anyone
literally for not doing
anything so here is um here's the
prosecutor trying to make the case that
this is a group of heroes who are going
to believe the narrative of your own
eyes
we've had several police officers
testify that an active shooter situation
their first
instinct their first training is to go
in and stop the threat
they don't sit there and wonder well
maybe it was self-defense i don't know
i'm gonna you know let wait and see
and every day we read about heroes that
stop active shooters
that's what was going on here
and that crowd was right
and that crowd was full of heroes
that crowd was full of heroes
the actual f
what in the world
and gets worse from here by the way
bingo decided it'd be a great idea to
point a gun at like the entire room
so number one
he's violating pretty much every
standard of gun safety right now
like there are pictures of written house
walking around in the middle of the
riots and obeying the basic rules of gun
safety like don't have your finger
inside the trigger guard
here is bingo with i mean it's like alec
baldwin over here
he's pointing an actual ar-15
style weapon
at the jury
because guns are scary guys and if kyle
rittenhouse had a gun and guns are scary
that means he's guilty in some way and
he's got his finger inside the trigger
guard
like
but
what
i'm sorry this guy's a mockery he's a
mop and then and then his deputy shows
up his deputy prosecutors get him james
krause and honest to god if this guy if
this guy bingo got his law degree from
from the university of cracker jack
boxes
then james grouse the ada apparently got
his degree from like a special k mail-in
game because
my god he then makes the case that
rittenhouse should have fought these
people with his fists
he says that if somebody attacks you
with their fists they're obviously not
going to do anything deadly to you so
you're a coward if you shoot them if
they're trying to beat the hell out of
you with a skateboard you have to take
the beating
clearly if there's provocation
he's guilty but even outside of
provocation
why do you get to immediately just start
shooting
as mr binger said he brought a gun
to a fistfight
and he was too cowardly to use his own
fists to fight his way out
okay so a few things i noticed that he
brought a gun to a gun fight considering
that gage gross which was showing up
with a gun
also he brought a gun to a being smashed
in the face with a skateboard fight also
he brought a gun to a somebody grabbing
for his gun fight
since i have a question since when in
american law is the rule that if
somebody threatens your life with not a
gun you're not allowed to use a gun to
protect your own life when is that the
rule in american law ever this is a real
bad day for the prosecution the defense
by contrast had a pretty easy day
because all they had to point out is the
obvious this is a political case here is
the defense attorney mark richards
making the point that this is a
political case which it clearly was
ladies and gentlemen
this
is a political case
we can take politics out of it as in
democrat and republican
but the district attorney's office is
marching forward with this case because
they need somebody to be responsible
they need somebody
to put
and say we did it he's the person who
brought terror to kenosha kyle
rittenhouse is not that individual
the rioters
the demonstrators who turned into
rioters
those are the individuals
who bring us forth
okay that is correct okay and then
richard says very controversially that
he's glad he shot joseph rosenbaum
well i mean i don't know about being
glad that anybody got shot but if
somebody's grabbing for a gun
and they get shot that is the
predictable result of grabbing for
somebody's gun
kyle shot joseph rosenbaum to stop a
threat to his person and i'm glad he
shot him because if joseph rosenbaum had
got that gun
i don't for a minute believe he wouldn't
have used it against somebody else he
was irrational
and
crazy
okay and not just that richards then
says that it's impossible
bingo had said it was impossible for
rose and moms who have threatened
written house that's of course untrue
and richards points that out
we showed the video to start this
clearly depicting mr rosenbaum standing
there at car source two
shortly after the dumpster
standing there with his chain
the shirt tied up over his head but mr
bigger says it's impossible for him to
have threatened my client that's garbage
just like his case
yup and then richards concludes by
saying that banger apparently lives in
fairy tale land because he's just making
up stories
this active shooter bs is something that
mr binger is trying to sell you people
has he shot anybody since car source 3
no he hasn't he's running to try and get
to the police
mr binger must live in fairy tale land
to think that kyle could stop
put his gun down and say hey
everything's good leave me alone i'm
going to the police unfortunately
that's not how the real world works
alrighty so in just one second we'll get
to the media's final take on this
particular situation because
at a certain point you have to imagine
that they want the riots
mischaracterizing the cases poorly as
they have done throughout this case
demonstrate they want something out of
this and apparently what they want is
more violence and more unrest because
the narrative uber alice the only thing
that matters is the narrative
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content